um like to begin we'd love to hear from
you
absolutely so just again for the record
for anybody else that's
new that's joined i'm caitlin davis i'm
from the department of education
i mean we are here doing a presentation
on the education trust fund portion of
the department of education's 2022 and
2023 biennium budget request
we are going to continue on with amy
clark the administrator of the bureau of
facilities
to talk about the public school
infrastructure fund and then charter
school lease aid and then our last topic
that we're going to be discussing today
um will be mark maganello who will be
talking about adequacy funding and
charter school funding
so amy
hello so again
amy clark for the department of
education you're also safe and facility
management
um see that
summary page
we'll all be able to see that on your
screen
um okay so the public school
infrastructure fund
um this is in your handout this is
somewhat um short but i have a summary
page
and a list of all the project reports
and so of the 42 pages you'll be happy
to know that
about 40 pages of it are the awards uh
so i just have this summary page here
and to talk a little bit about public
school infrastructure college
uh so again there's my contact
information
if you want to know more about it uh the
law is under
rsa 198.15
and essentially the public school
infrastructure fund in a nutshell
was established in 2017 the fund had a
total amount
of 28 million dollars available to
public schools which also includes
charter schools because of course
charter schools are public schools
uh and it reimbursed uh
schools for the following three types of
projects
um e-rate state match which is
essentially a federal program
that needed a state um
a matching um percent from the state so
this fund provided that match
and e-rate projects are simply to bring
fiber connection to schools so that
construction of the
fiber connection to the schools and that
was
type one type two was addressing
life safety uh deficiencies
at schools and then the third type was
improving security in schools
and just want to clarify because i think
a lot of times people get confused
between life safety and security when we
talk about
life safety think about the fire
marshal's office
think about like buildings being
condemned because
of um certain fire traps or
um things going on um that would be
hazardous to somebody's health
or um somebody being in danger
in the building itself security you can
think of that's the police department
that though the police department will
be happy that you're putting in since
improving security at your school so
security projects are
hardening schools in this particular
case pardoning schools
with door locks uh followers in front of
the school
uh vestibules security cameras and
things like that
so those are the three categories
um the status of the public school
um fund is that all of the awards have
been awarded and all the money has been
claimed
so um the public school infrastructure
fund
closed the awards um were final on
december
of 2020 so from 2017 to december of 2020
all the awards went out and all the
awards were claimed and there's no new
applications because there's no new
money in this fund
the public school infrastructure fund
commission is
two members of the house two members of
the senate
the director of homeland security and
emergency management
the commissioner of education the chair
of the school building authority
and the chair of the state board of
education so they formed a commission
in consultation with the governor um and
this commission
they awarded uh
awards to schools to perform one of
these three category types
um and in general of those three
categories the reimbursement rates were
for the e-rate state match because
that's what was required by the federal
government
of the state give a 10 match so that's
what the fund gave for the e-rate
projects
for the life safety projects that
depended on their building age rate
the commission decided that they would
grant out the building aid rate for
those projects which
was between 30 and 60 like we talked
about already
um and then for security projects it was
just a flat rate
um the commission chose a flat rate of
for any security related project
uh here's a summary of the quote
oh i think i can make that bigger um
here's a summary of those awards
you approved 31 million dollars almost
32 million dollars of awards
if you're like hmm that's weird i
thought you only got 28 million
well that is true but some people
um returned their award because they
were not able to either get the local
match
or they just withdrew their awards and
other people bought an award let's say
for 50
000 and they only spent 48 so i was able
to take that extra money
and put it back in the bucket and then
re-award that money
so that is slightly more um than what
the fund was
because money was returned for those
approved grants
for all three categories was about 32
million dollars
we paid 27 million dollars and
there was about four and a half million
dollars that one spent
um you can see there's a breakout
of if you're curious is to see like
where did this money go
e-rate you can see with a very very
small amount
all of the e-rate projects were approved
that that
put in a request there were just not
that many requests
um let's skip over and prove security
for a minute we could see life safety
um we paid out about three million
dollars
on life safety projects and if you're
thinking that doesn't also sound like
very much money um because it's only
10 of what was uh put out roughly
um well that's because life safety
projects in the law
have to be very specific life safety
projects
um the law requires that they be under
imminent danger
or substantial risk and those of those
definitions are actually
defined by the state fire marshal's
office and
you can tell that this is a situation in
a school where
these are pretty significant issues um
some of the some of those projects were
um to bring wooden structures up with
a sprinkler system um some of those were
like
installation of fire panels these were
like direct violations of the code
and that helped correct those problems
but
the main story of the public school
infrastructure fund
um is really that the public
really went to improve the security at
schools
and you could see 24 of the um 27
million went out to
schools that um to
to harden and harden their schools for
improving the security of the students
cameras doors locks security glass
vest of your check-in windows things
like that
and all schools that
wanted funds which were almost everybody
um was able to receive at least one
award
the clinician did a really good job of
reaching out to all the schools
they went through and and awarded money
and then they said oh let's let's hold
up
let's before we give you your third or
fourth award
let's check with all of those other
districts that maybe they haven't had
time to apply yet
and the commission worked really hard to
get everybody an opportunity that wanted
to
and i'd say 90 i don't know that's never
exact but i'm just going to say about 95
98 of the school districts received some
kind of award
there are a couple of schools that um
that did not
apply but most part um all our schools
received awards of some amount
um so there's that if you're wondering
well how many people applied
here's a summary of those applications
um a summary of how many were approved
not fruit there is a wait list so
there is a wait list of applications we
have run out of money
there are 59 applicants left on the wait
list
um totally about 1.2 million dollars
worth of frameworks
um keep in mind
that the commission um this was a first
in first come first serve however
if you had not received an award yet you
got to jump the line in front of anybody
that already received an award
so the 59 applicants
on that waitlist have already received
one two three four
five awards that doesn't mean they don't
want more you don't want to apply
that but um there's not 59 schools
that does not represent 59 schools they
didn't get securing money
um security money was um granted to all
schools that employed
and um 23 projects
and that's a break out by the category
now if you wanted to see i won't go
through the next 40 pages
uh amy excuse me just a second
um
so did the did the public school
infrastructure committee
meet to um give out
any of this 1.2 million
or is that going to lapse back into the
education
or someplace yeah those have been
approved by the commission
in the sense that if more money was
appropriated the commission has already
and the governor has already um said
that those are uh
projects that are on the waitlist but
there is no more money to homework
oh okay so didn't i see some place
uh you've got 1.2
to be returned to the um
general fund yeah um and that is because
um
those projects so when we got money back
we issued so i get money back from
schools then i issues the next person on
the waitlist money
however when december 30th closed
that's all the money that came in in the
last month and i have no time
to then reissue another award in
december because
the fund closed december 20th
december 2020. so yes i have extra money
but i have no way of
awarding it because it just came in
december and the award expires in
december
okay so basically this 1.2
uh is going to lapse to the general fund
in the end of this fiscal year
correct and you can see these just
happen to be
the numbers 1.237
will be returned and the amount on the
wait list is one point two three six
uh it just they're very close numbers
but yeah
that money will last and those people
will remain at the waitlist
um because the awards had uh officially
not technically but the award expired in
december 2020 and that will be collapsed
back into the
general fund okay thank you very much
uh representative heath you have a
question yes thank you
amy is there an action that we could
possibly take to get those funds
released so that those school districts
could get
benefit from those
uh the law i think you'd be uh
in rsa 198 15y there is
a um there is a deadline
for those awards um
so i don't i don't think the commission
could meet
and decide there just isn't enough time
so um then
the the project's gonna have to go to
fiscal and then go to gnc
and then the the school districts would
have to come up with their local chair
and we created the fiscal year thank you
sorry representative murray
yeah i think maybe mary sort of answered
it um
would and you know being relatively new
would these projects be appropriate in
hb2 is this something we could put in
hb2
of the specific projects that have been
approved but i think
um i heard amy say that the
school districts would still have more
work to do so that apparently wouldn't
be a mechanism
is that right well i can say that there
is
language in house bill 2 i believe
that's proposed
to extend the public school
infrastructure fund and put additional
money in
in there and so if that happens then i
imagine the commission could
decide uh whether to release these funds
or not
and keep these people going but the
current law is what kept what
um
thank you so yeah so the whole reason
why we actually
telling you guys about the public school
infrastructure today um is not just
because we want you to be aware of
what's happened in the past
but because the governor's office did
actually put 30 million dollars 15
million dollars in each year and
22 and 15 million dollars and 23
into the public school infrastructure
fund so had that not happened we
actually probably wouldn't be including
this information in our presentation
but we felt that it was important that
you know about the fund and you know
this is potentially something that may
be funded going forward and you
you will need to as a commission make it
or a committee rather make a decision on
that
with that said the public school
infrastructure fund has since
been amended after all the awards were
it is a little bit different written
last year it was um uh amended the law
was
and so now i think that there's um
eligibility for
hvac systems or in our systems that
improve
air quality that is in the public school
infrastructure fund
currently but by the time that was added
all the awards had already been uh
allocated out
and follow up yes please go ahead
um given the covet is there federal
money that can is
that might be coming in or to be used
for some of these projects
or uh not not the projects that are that
the commission currently looked at
because it did not include hvac
systems but if uh um but
to answer your question yes federal
money you can currently use esser funds
for
anything cobit related which is air
quality certainly
in hvac systems uh
try not to maybe i i'm just gonna say
this um keep in mind
that you can't you can't just take an a
track system and put it into an old
building and expect that it's going to
run efficiently
and work the way uh any nhv system
is designed to work for new buildings
relatively buildings uh definitely
maybe that's part of a different
[Music]
conversation
do you have anything else amy uh and
then lastly on the public school
infrastructure fund it's just a list
you'll see that all the rest of the
remaining pages are if you want to see
what your district received
um or any district received you can see
this is actually the status of
every award and so even though most of
these stay
paid in here um you will see some
um not many but you'll see some that
went unclaimed
in other words uh some like here was one
that's
withdrawn um so for some reason they
withdrew it
um you can scroll through and see the
status but
and then it has that grant category
remember i told you there were three
grant categories
the vast majority of them are going to
say improved security and then if you're
interested to see oh how much do they
unders
you know some of this money went back to
the public school infrastructure fund
this one came 619 underfunded
on you know they spent 619 less
so that money went back into the public
school infrastructure fund to be
reawarded
and it is amazing how these little when
you're talking about 30 million dollars
these little guys add up so um i was
pleasantly surprised we had a
five million dollar or four million
dollar wait list
and if we were able to fund almost
everybody on the waitlist
and that's it for the public school
infrastructure fund unless you have
questions
i would uh i would just like to say that
i did sit on that
commission and um
i think that we did a very good job
in allocating the money and
i can tell you that amy makes it look
easy here
uh it was it was not easy we had
if you think we got a lot of paperwork
on hb2
or all of this stuff we got about the
same amount on the public
infrastructure committee but it did a
lot of good things
for the state and hopefully we'll be
able to
uh put some money into it uh this year
so uh representative heath you have a
question i just wanna
ma'am chair i just wanna concur with
everything you're saying i too
am on the committee and i amy
you are remarkable and i just have to
thank you so much
because you made such an effort to spend
every single penny
you recalculate you do everything so
efficiently
so uh just to echo what our chair said
thank you very much you're welcome thank
you and the schools would reiterate that
too
about for you all for those that were on
commission the schools have reported
that you know essentially they applied
and then they sent the money and got
reimbursement
you know they they said they were gonna
buy cameras and they went about cameras
and
and uh it was a relatively uh painless
process
for them they're not always used to that
from especially from my office so that's
good
so i think next up unless you have more
questions about the public school
infrastructure fund
no thank you very much and uh caitlyn
take it over please
well you're you're not quite done with
amy yet we have one more topic for amy
to present which is
age of chartered public schools so i'm
sorry
excuse me no that's that's okay um
and so the final program here uh that is
out of my office
is the lease the charter school weekday
program
uh and can you see this all you can see
this it says lease 8 at the top
okay i never know if it switches when i
search so i'm glad
so um this is only three pages and
uh program summary and then the payments
itself
again there's my contact information if
you need me
um and for lisa um
that is under rsa 198 15 hh
and there are these day rules under 83
323 um least aid
is simply grant money to
assist public charter schools and
meeting the cost of their
annual lease payment and
these aid grants um the law
says that um that these aid covers
thirty percent
of their annual lease a payment up to
thirty thousand dollars for school
so i'd say a little more than half of
the schools
that full 30 percent covers their full
vca payment they don't get cash but then
probably the other uh 40 of schools
maybe
um are actually subject to the cat they
get what
um per year
um just keep in mind charter schools
that own
their own buildings are not eligible for
these aid it is specific
to uh unlease agreement
before uh the funding source is the
general fund
and the history of the save is really
that
lease date was created in in law in 2003
but it wasn't funded for the first time
until uh this little
20 20 pistol 20.
and so we've only had two appropriations
fiscal 20 and fiscal 21 the first year
was 200 000
and when i went when we went to pay the
of those payments with a cap of 30 000
we couldn't need those payments
so all the schools were prorated down to
so you can see that was a significant
reduction in payment
so in fiscal 21 so this data for
reprocreation was
500 000 uh and so i
was able to make fully aid payments
using that cap of thirty thousand
and the thirty percent total of my
we say payment of three hundred and
eighty two thousand dollars
so again the difference between these
will also go back
the laps back into the general
and if you're curious to see what those
payments were
um i will make this bigger but
there's the whole sheet it's all one
sheet um and you can see
the charter school name is here and this
is broken up into fiscal 20 and fiscal
21.
this is the eligible amount this is the
grant amount that had i had enough
appropriation i would have been able to
grant them
and then this is how much they were
prorated
um so you can see thirty thousand
dollars they were going to be paid 30
but their appropriation wasn't enough so
they were prorated down to 13 000.
you'll see this is a common number
because this is 44
of 30 000 and you see it down here
anybody that's half ended up at that 13
mark um so the total um
the total grant amount for 2020
was 200 000
um festival 21 the eligible fees amount
and then their grant amount i had enough
so they were not prorated i did not have
to provide schools
the total amount was that 382 000
and then um i included some people have
asked like oh what about that school or
what about that school
um and and here's the reasons
this year in fiscal 21 i went back and
asked schools why didn't you apply
sometimes it's because they don't have a
lease
you can see that some of these should
say no no these in some schools did not
apply for me
and that's all i have for lisa unless
you've got some questions
so uh amy the in the budget this year
i think was 500 000
again for 22 and 23.
and you indicated that it looked like
uh 385
would cover the leases
uh obvious that
does not include any new charter schools
that have
come online uh
for this year and is there more than one
that has come online this year
well i'll answer that question for amy
um so there are
two new charter schools that we are
expecting to open this fall
um so those two would obviously be
eligible for lease date and they're not
included here
additionally all of these schools that
you see on this list in front of you
that do not apply may actually apply
next year they didn't apply for whatever
various reasons a couple of them
had a couple issues obtaining some of
the documentation
other ones just couldn't apply by the
appropriate deadline and whatnot
so the 382 is the amount that was a
that applied and was approved this year
but 500 000
may not end up fully funding everybody
um including the two new schools and the
existing schools if everybody does
choose to apply
and also keep in mind there is uh
unfortunately i don't have the house
bill number in front of me but that
there is a house bill out there that
increases the cap
from 30 000 to 50 thousand
and that that small change would already
put it over
five hundred thousand if that if that
cap existed in fiscal 21
this total would have been like 520 000
or something like
that okay thank you very much uh
representative heath your vienna yes
thank you madam chair
um the there's been a federal award of
quite a large
sum of money um can any of that money be
used
for uh rent purposes so
we are in the process of working through
the what is and is not allowable in the
federal grant with the us department of
education
however under the last charter school
grant that we received
we were allowed to reimburse schools
for three months prior to opening for a
portion of
lease expenses so it was only for the
three months prior to opening after they
opened they are not received
their ll's refer anything we don't know
if those same
requirements or allowabilities are under
this grant or not yet
we haven't received that documentation
from the feds
all right thank you which makes sense if
it's a startup if it's a startup grant
which is probably why it would cover on
some of the first few months at the
least
okay that is it unless you have some
questions
no i don't want to cut you off but
thank you very much and you've done a
great job as always
okay caitlin it's now your turn i think
so um yes but this year i've actually
firmed up my presentation
um so this year we are very lucky to
have mark miganello on staff here at
department of education
um and he is going to be taking
everything that he learned with helping
division two with the last biennium
budget and everything he learned
learned with working with mickey um and
trying to give his best shot at the
adequacy presentation i'll be here
um if he needs any assistance or if
there's any questions but i think mark
has really got it
completely under control so mark
oh can you hear me can you see my screen
we can hear you now um
for the record mark manganello with the
department of education uh you received
a 46-page pdf
um try to go through it quickly try to
uh touch upon the key points here
uh there's a table of contents to
reference back to those documents
um this is a summary and if you worked
with me with my legislative email this
is my doe
email now a couple of things to point
out in state fiscal year 2020
full day kindergarten was added into the
state adequacy aid formula
so prior to that um it was only half day
kindergarten so it was
bumped up to full day and moved into
adequacy there was a program
prior to 2020 called kino garden but
that program was replaced by just
putting full day kindergarten in
adequacy
also in 2020 stabilization grants were
restored to the
[Music]
2012 level and so stabilization grants
are changes to the formula made in 2011
that negatively impacted the revenue
towns
schools received from the state in 2012.
if you
if due to changes in the formula you
lost state funding for your school
you received a stabilization grant and
then in 2017
changes in the law made it so that those
grants would phase out over a 25-year
period and they would phase out by
four percent reduction each year over 25
years
so in 2020 those reductions stopped and
those grants were restored to 100
of the 2012 level um and those changes
exist in current law today
so they exist in 2021 and they will
exist
under current law in 2022 um another
change in 2021 that you've probably
heard about is the one-time aid
so that was 60 million dollars it was
added to the adequacy aid formula
in 2021 but it also expires in 2021 so
it's one time eight it's a one-time
addition to the formula but is set to
expire at the end of this year so will
not be available in 2022
under current law um other things to
note and the commissioner talked a lot
about this
is the fnr issue with the usda waiving
the documentation
requirements that families complete
those
complete those applications in order to
be eligible for free and reduced-priced
meals they're just eligible
automatically
and so it's great for those families but
at the same time it creates
data issues for the department because
we use that documentation to calculate
adequacy
and uh the commissioner talked about
communities are trying their best to get
those
those applications in but it's still a
challenge
and so that's an issue going on because
of the pandemic
and then um when you look at enrollment
numbers in this stock in this
46-page pdf you'll see some enrollment
data um
enrollment data historically declines at
around one percent ish
um each year but this year a four
percent decline
so um some families are leaving the
public school system
um and we're seeing that reflected in
the enrollments
and this is uh caitlin introduced this
document this just shows school
aid appropriations in a different table
this document is produced by the lba so
mickey published this in
january 2020 i think so
and this just explains the adequacy aid
formula for
charter schools so with charter schools
you have uh
the regular cost of inadequate at cost
of inadequate education components
so you have base aid which is eight
seven hundred eight dollars
and seventy eight cents uh times the
number of pupils you have
and then you have a few differentiated
aid categories so for each
eligible um people eligible for
free and reduced price meal they receive
eighteen hundred dollars and fifty four
cent uh
uh one thousand eight hundred fifty four
dollars and thirty eight cents
uh per each pupil eligible so that's the
part of the
formula that's being impacted by the
pandemic because of those waivers
uh the number of pupils is decline is a
lot lower than we would expect
um so that's impacting the cost of an
adequate education which determines your
aid
and then there's also english language
learners um
for each english language learner you
have you get an a 725
and this is for a state fiscal year um
2020 and 2021
and then for each um each people
receiving special education services you
receive 1995
and 21 cents and then for each
third grade third grader who below
scored
below proficiency on the third grade
reading test and is not in any one of
these categories
the school would receive dollars and
725.63 cents for each one of those
peoples
so that's the adequacy formula uh but
this is
explaining charter schools and charter
schools receive an additional grant per
pupil
of 3479.22
and that would result in your total
charter school age
and then there's a updated document
mickey produced recently
the lba produced and it just has cpi
adjustments so no changes have been made
to this formula
between these two bienniums at the
moment
except for the cpi adjustments are
reflected here so
representative heath you have a question
yes please
thank you ma'am chair um what is the
total figure then
so the total charter figure is 3479
plus the base adequacy um
so the the charter school figure oh so
this would be
um you're you're you're gonna get a base
oh so yeah you
for per pupil you would get um whatever
the number is the 3708
plus that but then if you have students
um qualifying for these eligibilities
you could potentially be eligible for
those amounts as well
so it was just ma'am chimi mayor please
certainly um so they get all the
add-ons um but they have that uh
straight
base of 3470 plus
the base adequacy plus the add-ons
that's correct thank you um and madam
chair if i could ask one more question
please
certainly um this question is in
relation to the one-time
60 million dollar funding based on
disparity aid
can you tell me did every district in
the state get that or just those with
a high percentage of freedom reduced
lunch students
yep so that's a good question um that
aid was targeted
so if you had um the fiscal capacity
disparity aid was based on your
equalized valuation per pupil
so if you look at your equalized
valuation of your property and you
divide it by the pupils
you get a evpp an equalized valuation
per pupil
and any any community that had an
equalized valuation per pupil
under a million dollars was eligible for
fiscal capacity disparity
so some communities have really high
equalized valuation
per pupil and some have really low so
not every not every school
qualified for that grant and then the
the other component of the 60 million is
the additional aid based on free and
reduced
uh price meal uh population percentage
so that one you were eligible if you had
your percentage of fnr eligible students
was greater than 12
of your total school population um then
you were eligible for that grant and
those grants were sliding scales so
those numbers vary depending on where
you are in that metric representative
heath we actually have
further down in the packet um the entire
2021 town by town
amounts so you'll be able to see exactly
which towns did and didn't receive a
grant
and then we also put together a document
per representative
berger's request that shows all one-time
aid that was received in fiscal year 21
to date
which actually includes the esser cares
money and the one-time adequacy funding
so those are later on in the packet and
we will get to those as well perfect so
thank you
yep so that was um this is the
describes the charter school calculation
for the current biennium we're going
into
this document is um just sort of a
breakdown by charter school of the
governor's recommended charter school
aid
for 2022 and 2023 um
just kind of we've already noted this
there's two new schools expected to go
live
in this next biennium and these are you
know estimated enrollments
um for those um those schools
and then you can this should link up to
the what you see in your budget
budget package so uh this is only the
uh pupil aid not not
the um lease aid correct this is just
the charter school like charter school
adequacy
correct thank you
this next document um it kind of
describes uh charter's charter school
adequacy
in the way you might be similar to
seeing district public school adequacy
in this more
horizontal format so this just walks you
through 2020 and what that looked like
and you can
see the how the charter school moves
through the formula
this next document is uh 2007 to 2000
uh 2007 to 2021
charter school average daily membership
in attendance and we have the new
schools on here they're showing blanks
for 2021 because they're not going to
open
by june 30th and some close charter
schools and you can
kind of see the history of charter
school
this is the district public school
formula which is different there's some
similarities with the charter school aid
formula but
a little bit different so just like
charter schools
charter schools receive adequacy
constitutional adequacy
district public schools as well so the
same formula
generally applies there for the cost of
inadequate education
the difference is um something called uh
swept the statewide education property
tax so
the state applies a statewide property
tax
known as swept and and what it does is
it the state needs to raise 363 million
dollars for the swept
and what it will apply at tax across all
the properties in the state
and it's about around two dollars per
thousand
and that's the statewide education
property tax and that money is raised
locally and it's retained locally so it
never makes its way to the state
it's um kept by the locals and so
when you run the adequacy calculation
you do the base a you do the
differential aid
you determine this amount which is the
cost of inadequate education
but there's something goes on it's
referred to excess swept
so if you had a community that had
really high value properties
that two dollars per thousand tax rate
might raise say two million dollars
but when you add up all their students
using these calculations
their cost of inadequate education might
only be a million dollars
so that's sometimes referred to
sometimes referred to as donor towns but
they get to keep that money so they
don't donate it
the local community gets to keep it but
that's called excess swept so if you
hear that term xsweb
that's where that term comes from but
when you're calculating aid for a
district public school you first
figure out the cost of an adequate
education you net it against any money
they raise locally through that tax
it's a state tax but it's raised locally
retained locally
so for some people they might just keep
their swept and they may be done with
the formula
but if their cost of inadequate
education was two million dollars
and they raised one million dollars who
swept then their preliminary grant would
be a million dollars it'd be the net of
the difference
then uh we talked a little bit about
stabilization um mickey's document
explains it and there's some
some eligibility issues with um if
you're in excess swept town you don't
receive stabilization it doesn't impact
a lot of communities
but um cost of adequate education netted
against the swept
add the stabilization grant and then for
state fiscal year
2021 only
you added in those additional ways and
mickey kind of explains how those
programs work in these little
little charts here and then you add in
fiscal capacity disparity aid which we
talked about
and that would equal the total education
grant for 2021.
uh this is another lba document
um which describes the biennium or the
fiscal year about to go into
and um a lot of the same components cost
of adequate education the same you minus
net against the swept
you add in stabilization but those
one-time aides are not there anymore
so that's an important thing to note
uh this is the um
current law 2020 2021
and then 20 state fiscal year 2022 and
this is this shows what the governor
has uh proposed for state adequacy and
if you had a chance to look at hb2
the governor has a language in there to
fix the fnr issue
that communities are dealing with so we
normally see around 45 000 um
45 000 eligible fnr pupils in the state
that numbers drop down to around 34 000
so it's a very significant drop because
of that usd wave
usda waiver issue so when you look at
current law
it's it's a really it's pretty low and a
lot of that is because of the fnr issue
so the governor has a calculation for
when determining fnr the department will
look at your drop in enrollment and look
in your drop in your fnr
and you drop the percentage drop in your
enrollment your adma
cannot ex uh the drop in your fnr cannot
exceed the drop you see in your students
so if you had no drop in your students
between state fiscal year
2021 and 2022 but you saw a really big
drop in your fnr
you would bring your fnr population back
to what you had pre pandemic
and so when you run that calculation
based on current law brings it up 16 or
16.7 million dollars
so that's the the governor's budget
which um
just the only change it makes to
adequacy is just calculating how many f
r pupils will go into the equation
excuse me mark
you said if if the
school population dropped
then
that is that is going to be the new
figure for
2022 um so
there's there's a better document i
actually probably misspoke because
adequacy
it's a year behind so let's see if we
can it's a
it's towards the end um let's see if i
can get to that quickly
okay no problem uh matt you have a
question or a comment
mickey could you bring that up yeah he
uh i just brought madden he should be
able to speak now
okay thank you yes hello chairman amber
members of the committee
i just wanted to uh see if i could help
clarify the
formula and thank you mark for for
walking the committee through that
essentially another way to think about
how that fnr correction
um is intended we're looking at the
historical percentage of students
who are enrolled who qualify for free
and reduced lunch
and using that metric that percentage of
students
and applying it to the most updated
enrollment figures
right so that historical share of
students that would have qualified
we know that there's been a federal
change
that has artificially brought down the
number of families that are
filling out the the paperwork but we
know the need hasn't changed if anything
that need has increased
so with that looking at if you had 100
students before the pandemic and 28
qualified for fnr we would take that 28
and multiply it by the most updated
enrollment
uh and mark correct me if you have any
different interpretation but i think we
said the same thing
uh just going at it from slightly
different directions yep no there's a
lot
of way to describe this situation i like
that way
think about it as a pre-pandemic ratio
and that ratio is frozen in time and
you're guaranteed that ratio and that
ratio is your
fnr relative to your total student
population
so they're going to hold you harmless to
that ratio that's what the governor's
budget does
so the the enrollment
number is going to be the enrollment
for 2021.
okay and you indicated
that we had a four percent drop
in school enrollment in 2021
yep so the governor didn't change the
way the
base adequacy enrollment so just a
student regular student
enrollment the governor didn't change
the way we calculate that we'll use the
whatever the numbers are going to be at
the end of the year we'll use those
numbers
based on the governor's proposal but
what the governor did change was
how the fnr pupil amount so that
differentiated category
how that is calculated um we will use uh
the la
if hp2 passes we'll use that language um
currently in hb2 to bring that number up
so
um rev uh some base adequacy will
decline
because enrollments are declining so
base adequacy will decline but fnr will
grow
um under the governor's proposed and i
just want to
i want to point out too so that when
we're talking about the four percent we
looked at
as of october first on 2000 2020
compared to october 1st of 2019 so
that's where we're seeing the four
percent decline
um there will be an opportunity for
school districts to
change those or end or update those
enrollments at the end of the year
and so a school district may only end up
with a three percent decline or no
decline at all
especially if a school for example had
kids at the beginning of the year that
chose to stay home because the school
was
um using remote instruction for the
first two months a year then then came
in person and the kids came back in
person
we are still expecting a higher than
normal one perc that one percent decline
but there are opportunities for schools
to update that information
so this enrollment includes
uh children that are doing full remote
learning yes
okay so it's in person
plus remote as long as the child
continues to be enrolled in a public
school now if a child is doing remote
learning and is now
either doing remote learning through a
non-public school or enrolled in a
homeschool program meaning they sent a
letter of intent to homeschool
to either the commissioner or a public
or non-public school in the state
there is no adequacy now being paid for
those kids
but if the kid is at home being
instructed by the public school district
um and just take participating the
physical location of the instruction is
at home
they are included in the base adequacy
counts
uh do we have any idea what happened to
the home school percentage of students
we do um we have an estimated home
school percentages actually on another
slide
when we get to it but it did it did
increase substantially this year
okay thank you yep and yeah we have some
towards the bottom of the package
there's a lot of enrollment data um
which is really helpful i was gonna try
to toggle quickly to it but um we'll get
to that um
soon enough so this is just a town by
town with
the governor's proposed budget
so we don't have a 2023
yet is that correct that's correct
i think at this point um any estimates
by the department to try to estimate
23 would be i think would likely be
wildly off because
we have we're not even sure what's going
to happen with covid and you know
enrollments
um i think that we might be able to do a
better
job maybe estimating 23 um by the end of
the school year but certainly not in
time for the budget
so what do i do put zero in the budget
for 23.
it's probably not the best plan um
that's an option right okay
um fiscal 23 in the governor's
recommended budget though is using the
same
factor yes yes yeah yeah so it's
basically
uh budgeted at the same enrollments and
and everything reserved right now i mean
we certainly we tried to do
a estimate but we just don't have any
enrollment data to you know
to see if that's going to be super
accurate or not
and you might want to remind them about
the warrant that is in statute just
you know when the budget amount doesn't
align with the actual needed
yes so yeah if the department of engine
the department of education has the
authority to
draw a warrant regardless of what the
appropriation awarded to us for
adequacy is and this is for both
traditional regulars public school
adequacy and charter school adequacy
so for example last year we
only had i forget the exact number
actually 100 and say maybe 61 million
dollars of appropriation for adequacy
but our total adequacy bill was around
or sorry 961 million and our total
adequacy bill was 963 million
so what the process is in the department
of education draws a warrant on the
education trust fund to get that excess
appropriation
the other on the other side of things so
for fiscal year 21
we had about 12 million dollars of
excess appropriation and education trust
fund well as if we're
anticipating that right now we have one
final adequacy calculation that we do in
april every year
so we do have that flexibility it is
very helpful
um when you know we're talking about two
or three years out and the kids aren't
even in the schools yet
especially in a year like this year
well i'll keep on moving through the
slides and then we'll get to some
enrollment data shortly
uh so this is uh 2021 this is a
adequacy spreadsheet that shows you if
you want to walk a town through the
formula you can
see the components and see them through
the different columns
and just this is important too because
this has the fiscal capacity aid
and the free and reduced lunch aid so
you can see some towns are here like a
town like hampstead didn't
receive um an additional grant for free
and reduced lunch
or for um or for the equalized valuation
but then you have some towns like rotten
they received an additional free reduced
lunch count but they didn't
receive anything from equalized
valuation because they have a very high
equalized valuation and groton
yep so yeah that 12 threshold they they
didn't
achieve that threshold so they didn't
get any additional aid and then their
evp over a million dollars so they
didn't qualify for fiscal capacity to
spare you that's just that
that town for example
this is still town by town for 2021
here's adequacy for 2022 current law
so um if you looked up above the total
adm was 167 for 2021
now it's gone down to 160 so that's
about a four percent drop
um the fnr numbers 45 000 and 2021
but current law at the moment and
current data that we have
we did a cursory scrub of the data the
number this number is growing
so it will get bigger as the year
progresses
um but it still appears to be a problem
as that communities are facing
but yeah you'll see that 45 000 that
drops down under current law and current
data
34 000 so that's a 24 drop
and then the governor's budget redoes
this calculation
to bring these numbers up and i think he
his budget brings it up to around 44 000
so it doesn't totally bring the bud up
to 45.6
000 but brings it up to closer to that
number
and that's a state fiscal year 2022
current law
not the governor's proposed but this
current law representative heath
thank you ma'am chair so i'm a school
district
um i've been given my allocation
caitlyn sent those out to school
districts and i'm going into my town
meetings
it's it's a town voting day is coming up
and i've had to prepare my budget based
on the
numbers that have been given me
by the department based on what they
have they that's what it had to be
um so i am ending up um
looking like we're having a a big drop
when
in fact based on hb2 it might not be as
big
um and there are a couple of bills
coming through
of the house and senate right now that
maybe we'll look at the enrollment
numbers being
held harmless so if i'm a school
district what do i do
what would i say to my constituents if
they asked me
um what budget should i put in
to address the needs that are happening
right now in my schools
well i kind of hate to pass the bucket
on that pass the buck on this one
but the department of revenue really
controls what they will allow the school
district to put in for our budget
um and estimated aid so um
we are going to have to
work with the department school is going
to have to work with the department of
revenue
and i'm not sure if you know they have a
process to say you know
we actually have found 50 free and
reduced lunch kids
and so then we can actually add them in
or
or or are they i'm not actually sure
what the dra
respon response that is but you're
absolutely correct that if the school
district is using the november 15th
estimate the department of education has
to
prepare the in law so we have no
flexibility
on what to do with that calculation that
a school district may be using a lower
than
um actual state revenue
okay thank you great answer caitlin
and and uh there is an opportunity as
some of that money comes in
they can hold they can retain some of
that money a certain percentage of it
um but you're right it is budgeting
challenge because the state budget will
come after
likely come after a school budget uh
mary i think the best thing to do at
this point is flip a coin
i agree
um so um similar to the governor's
budget um
was redesigning how to calculate the
the amount of pupils there's another
bill out there in the senate
senate bill 135 and it's a different a
different calculation to
deal with enrollment issues and so what
senate bill 135 does is it looks at
what are your enrollment numbers this
year for all your
base adequacy accounts your fnr counts
your ell counts or sped counts
all of those counts and goes what was it
this year what is it last year pick the
bigger of the two numbers
so based on
senate bill senate bill 135
over current law it's about 45 million
dollars so
28 million or 30 million dollars over
the governor's budget
but that's another proposed um
enrollment
uh recalculation nothing to the formula
except for how we
decide how many students to count and
this is a town by town so you can also
see that
and then oh so this is the pupil data
and um
it's kind of get tripped up when you
talk about adequacy because the student
count is always
a year behind so we're going to be using
these numbers
the 2021 school uh 2021 school year
we're going to be using that for state
fiscal year 22
and the 1920 school year is going to be
used for state fiscal year 21
so there's always a lag in the data as
far as when you get paid
and so this just shows you some of those
enrollment numbers and you can see town
by town how your account is doing
this is their total pupils so total
students and then
most most communities have seen a
decrease some communities have grown
their
their number of students like ashland um
and then this is the free and reduced
price meal eligible students
and so some communities have increased
the number of students they have
with that for that population but again
most have seen a decrease
you can see this town by town
um this is a bigger picture enrollment
um
table and so this shows you
different grade levels it goes back 10
years
so this is the average change year over
year for the 10 year period
so i actually took out this last because
state fiscal year 20 the number is
impacted by the pandemic i took this out
and this number gets closer to one
percent
which is kind of in line with what we've
seen historical if you take out
this year as an anomaly but um over the
10-year period it's uh
enrollment's declined by 1.6 and just a
point
for people too so there were a lot of in
the fall newspaper articles talking
about like a six or seven percent
decline
in various different districts and
across the state and i know you just
heard mark when i say a four percent
decline
um part of that is because if you look
at you know so if you look at
preschool for example there was almost a
50 reduction in the number of preschool
kids in public schools so when you're
talking about statewide numbers we use
p through 12. um however when we're
talking about adequacy we're only
talking about k
through 12. um so that's just one of the
things that i just wanted to point out
just
because there's been some confusion of
that
so this is okay preschool
okay plus all right thank you
yeah yeah that's okay the top says
public and
private fall enrollment
where where am i seeing
sorry it should say republican yeah
it should say public uh public and
non-public so this is private right here
okay so if i'm looking at this correctly
it's 16 994
in private schools yes that is the
enrollment
that reported to us as of this fall
okay thank you so that their enrollment
also dropped they actually had a slight
increase from 20 to 21
um but they have can they have uh
experienced declines across the state
just like the traditional public schools
i'm at about the same one percent rate
that this the public schools have
experienced
sorry i was reading the wrong numbers
yep this this percentage is over the
10-year period but
and then the homeschool home educated
students that's self-reported data so
it's not as reliable as say our public
school data
um but um this is what's been reported
to us that number's jumped up a good
amount
and then this is representative von
berger this is actually the spreadsheet
that you had asked for
specifically which shows the one-time
aid
the federal funding that the school
districts have received
and then additionally the one-time state
aid
so we're not actually prepared to talk
to you about the
federal one-time aid today during part
of this meeting
i believe tammy allen court will cover
that at a later date when she talks
about the bigger department of education
budget and some of our federal funding
um but you did ask for this so um we put
on here so we have
our enrollments and then we have to date
we've the schools have received
or there's been allocated to schools um
three
large grants and then some some smaller
here and there grants but three large
school
grants that most schools in the state
have received um as part of
the federal aid packages that the state
of new hampshire has received
sr-1 is part of the cares act and the
state received
about 34 million dollars that was
distributed to schools plus an
additional amount the state received
sps rf funding was an additional amount
of money that the governor
allocated directly out of the money that
the discretionary
money that the state had um this
governor chose to allocate to schools uh
200 per school for every single student
in response to kova 19
and then an additional 10 million
dollars of discretionary money that
schools could
apply for if they had costs above and
beyond the two the 200
per student so that was about 45 million
across the state
and then we have a draft sr2 allocation
so that's from the federal
carissa grant which was essentially
coveted cares act number two
which is going to bring another 140
million dollars across the state to be
allocated to school districts
to mitigate coba 19 related
expenses and both sr1 and sr2 were
allocated in a proportional amount to
the title 1 formula
that is in the federal law meaning the
department of education didn't have any
ability to kind of modify that formula
or whatnot
and um the sr1 allocation we put it in
fiscal year 21 because the department
uh distributed it at the end of fiscal
year 20 and school districts
um really hadn't gotten a chance to
spend any of it in 21 so most of it
really it will be
sorry in 20. so most of it will be spent
in 21. um the draft sr money that was
allocated
or the schools were total total of the
award several weeks ago and that money
is going out
soon and then obviously we have the
one-time grants that we've talked about
a few times throughout this presentation
and that money
was received by the schools beginning in
september
and so this is all the one-time money so
school districts it's uh you can see
it's a pretty hefty number across the
state of 270 million dollars of
one-time unanticipated funding that
schools receive
so will the s for two money carry over
to next year
yes okay so it's it okay good
thank you and i mean there's a potential
for another award to me they're talking
about the federal stimulus package that
was passed um
i think it was over the weekend by the
house it was needs to go through the
senate
um the senate is who knows what they'll
end up doing with it but you know that
it's potentially quite a bit of money
that's going to the state
um mark also just scrolled down to the
last feature that shows that charter
schools were also eligible
um for ester one ester ii spsf funding
they did not receive the extra one-time
disparity aid in the funding formula
um for whatever reason but so this is
this is the the one-time money that
they're receiving federally
thank you i can't i can't read well i
can read the numbers but i'll
i'll look at it when i receive it from
mickey
yeah so that's all we have for our
presentation today and we'll
you know we actually have a half hour
left we'll take any questions anything
that we can discuss
um about the topics that were discussed
today i mean i do just want to remind
the committee that i believe you have
i think it's on monday another meeting
scheduled with tammy vallancourt the
department cfo to discuss
individual department programs and
department operations
yes that's that's absolutely correct and
uh
tell tammy we're very nice people okay i
will
are there any further questions for
caitlin oh yes
mayor uh represent murray i see you have
your hand raised
thank you um back on page 41
can you just give a few words about the
holmes educated students it's fairly
it's quite an erratic number up and down
um
i mean even from it's hard for me to
read some of the years i guess it's 15
to 16 to 16 to 17 that's a big drop and
then it's
creeping back up um any insight into why
those numbers
change that dramatically so the the
change in the numbers is i think mostly
relative to the way that homeschool kids
reported
so in the past all homeschool kids had
to report to the school district school
districts reported information directly
to the department of education
the laws change and so homeschool kids
only need to be reported to the
department of education
once in a child's career and it could be
reported to the department
to a non-public school to a public
school so the data reporting side of
things just changed we're not sure if
the number of home school kids changed i
don't
believe that it it did it's just more of
a
self-reporting mechanism hasn't resulted
in the same type of data being reported
to the department
uh follow-up please is that a
problem in terms of the information that
you're getting around the students are
you missing information that you
used to get there's no department
there's no information the department is
required to collect that we're not
receiving
but the department is not really
required to receive very much at all on
on home school children so
okay are there any further questions or
comments
okay once again i really really want to
thank
everyone from doe for talking to us
and we will have um a
great deal of information to uh to look
at
to think about and uh to try to come to
come to grips with um how we're
and what we're going to do and since
we didn't think that zero was a good
idea for 23.
we'll have to uh also also
think about that and and what uh what we
need to do
so if there's nothing else um
i will just say i will uh
see all of you um tomorrow
i just want to say to thank you for to
the committee for taking the time to
listen to us today talk about our
programs
these programs are very important to the
department and the staff that
administer them i think you probably see
that today from some of the passion that
they
express when they're talking about their
programs um and so we really appreciate
you taking the time to listen
so make sure that you have all the
appropriate information that you need
when making very large budget decisions
that we know that are not taken lightly
um so if you know if you need anything
you know mickey knows how to find us
you all know how to find us so reach out
whenever you can
okay thank you i would like to say that
next
tuesday is um
town meeting day i
i don't know how many of you are going
to be involved
in the town meeting business but
um we decided not
to meet on tuesday of next week because
of town meeting
and mickey did we get set up for friday
uh it's gonna be scheduled now so the
first uh three for next week
monday with doe wednesday i believe with
safety thursday with dot and
janet scheduling friday now
i think waiting for a time you want to
do 10 o'clock
yes okay
oh um how long we run
[Music]
on each of those days we'll be uh
extremely dependent on the number of
questions that we have
but i hope that we have a lot of
questions
because i think it's important that we
are able to fully understand the budget
and
as hopefully all of you know
um ways and means did us no favor
when they uh when they put out the uh
projected revenue so they're gonna be
some hard decisions that
uh that we have to make and it's not
it's not just in general funds it's in
all the funds so we'll uh
we'll keep smiling and um
hopefully we'll uh we'll manage to get
through this
um we also will have some bills
that we'll need to hold public hearings
on
that came out of last wednesday and
thursday's
um session so
i don't know uh man i'm sure
am i understanding correctly that you're
what you're anticipating is next week we
will be meeting
on not on tuesday but monday wednesday
thursday and friday
that's correct okay great all right
thank you
oh you know i i hope no one minds
that we meet for the morning and
basically have
generally have the afternoon free to do
other things um i personally find that
better for me because i have i think
we all have uh zoom meetings running out
of our ears
and so it does allow us to
schedule those other things in the
afternoon so
hopefully um everybody is doing well
uh kate you got your first shot right
i'm sorry
you got your first my first shot and no
side effects except you know
it kind of made me feel sort of happy in
the head
oh i don't even have a thought this is
just so relaxing but i think i don't
know if that was me or the shock
oh well we had a we had a cartoon in our
paper
um on saturday i think it was where uh
a person was sitting in a chair and
obviously hadn't gotten their
covert shot and then a person that had
gotten their coveted shot
skipping across the floor so
okay so mary where do you stand on your
covet shot
i've already had one shot and i've got
my second shot on march 18th so i'm
almost there okay representative lynn
i'm i'm getting my first shot on friday
um
in fact i i'm uh it's at noon time so i
may have to
and it's in londonderry so i may have to
bow out a little early
and then they'll schedule me for my
second one that day so
hopefully it'll be not too long and
i've had both shots so
we'll uh what can i say
and tom what about you
i have i have received one and i'm
waiting on uh
the second one and
mickey you are so young that
[Music]
now now they did say that the group 1b
will be um you know finished
sometime in april which is which is
really good
and then we'll go on to the the next
group
so and then we've got the johnson and
johnson coming out so
all kinds of good things going to happen
so
with that i will um
see you all tomorrow morning at 10
o'clock
thank you everybody take care thank you
bye bye everybody